Let's explore like those who strive to travel the sea.
Ready for action, without hesitation, to cross the equator, demonstrating their courage.
Full of honor, without retreating, without fainting, let's explore.
Neither storm nor darkness will stop us.
With a common goal, under the blue sky, new directions to follow.
Without ever thinking of climbing, overcoming adversity.
Let's explore.
Full of restlessness, to another latitude.
We must sail with hearts full of hope.
When the hurricane rages, we navigate with eagerness.
Adventure is a duty for the purpose of being the first.
Let's explore.
Let's satisfy our curiosity once again.
Brave fighter, the explorer, always taking a step further.
Never giving up for the good of humanity.
What do you think, Captain Cook?
It's a fine botanical collection.
We'll call this Cove Botanical Bay.
I take possession of this land in the name of England.
At last they're leaving.
There were too many of them.
We don't have enough animals and plants to feed them all.
There will.
Be peace now.
they will surely return and be more numerous in truth australia was discovered before captain cokey
long before the dutch and french sailors do you know that the first discoverers arrived on foot
on foot that is not possible australia is surrounded by water it has not always been an
island you should know that about 50 000 years ago there was a period of great cold the water
transformed into glaciers and the water level dropped so tasmania was connected to australia
and here to the north. Australia was connected to New Guinea and Indonesia. And so men are always
curious. Where are we going, dad? I don't know, son. We have to find a place where there is game.
There are too many of us here. As happened in those days, men had to migrate because of hunger.
But let's go back to our story after Captain Cook left. I hope they don't come back. If they do,
there will be nothing to eat. But in England the authorities decided otherwise. Hum. These new
lands are the Inna and could house our overcrowded prisons. You are quite right, Mr. Pitt. We will
send our prisoners there. Move. The Marquise de Grundle tells me that. Look, they are coming back.
They are numerous. Yes, too numerous. Captain Arthur Phillip, I appoint you governor of this
colony. The secretary's name is Lord Sidney. The bay we found will be called Sidney from now on,
and knowing the wonders of our civilization, I am sure that one day it will be a city.
Dear children, let us pray for our salvation. Come in. Who is it?
My name is Matthew Funders, naval officer and cartographer.
And who is the other one? But I am alone. But this one does not fly anymore.
What do you two want?
Governor, I have explored New Zealand. It is an enormous island, like a continent.
But what are you saying? Look, well, it may be. So what?
Well, it would not be New Holland, but the southern continent.
I think we should call it Australia. The Australian continent.
Australia says, but which Australia? We're in New Wales, which is part of New Holland.
It makes me laugh. Australia, that's good. I've never heard of anything like it.
Australia. The beginning of the 19th century, only a few ports and small towns were founded
on the coast of Australia. Bazaars, Albany, Per, Hamara, Brisbane, Adelaide, Melbourne, Darwin.
But what could there be in the interior of that immense country? Look at this map of Australia.
I was the first to discover the rivers, the Darwin, the Murray, but the rest of the country
is just a big white spot. I want to be the first to explore it too. Count on me to help you organize
the expedition. Ah, we won't make it. We have to turn around. In 1848, the explorer Frider Wilhelm
Blutter tried to cross that continent. He probably disappeared when he was swept away by a flooded
river. Another explorer, John Septimborough, also tried. He didn't succeed, but he got married,
had 13 children and was happy, and another one, Edmund Burley Kerr Kennedy, who was murdered by
aborigines for unknown reasons. Many more tried throughout the century following in Captain Cook's
footsteps, but no one managed to cross that continent until the day. Well, I'm telling you
that's not true, Tom. Can you believe me? Gentlemen, Australia is English land. We know
it's a continent, but no one has ever managed to cross it. Not from north to south, not even from
east to west. And, gentlemen, this can't go on like this. It's strange. And what can we do?
A reward. That's a reward. Excellent idea. M. The South Australian government is offering a reward
of 2,000 pounds for the first expedition to reach the north. 2,000 pounds. A fortune. Yes,
but no one has ever made it. Crossing Australia is very dangerous. 2,000 pounds. Do you understand?
What news? What news? Give me that. What? 2,000 pounds. My wig. Gentlemen, we must react. We can't
let the people from Adelaide beat us. No, your honor. Let's offer more. 2005. Mr. Stewart,
everything is ready to begin the expedition. Set off as soon as possible. I am ready,
Governor. William Kevick will accompany me. Ready, Kevick. Ready, Mr. Stewart. Mr. Berg,
we chose you six months ago to lead the expedition. What are you waiting for to set
off. This is what I have been waiting for, your honor. Camels, camels from Afghanistan. Ships in
the desert can go days and days without water. Now we can set off. The wagons are delayed again.
While we wait, we will build a barrier. We must protect ourselves from the savages.
Who are those? They are men who come from the sea in big wooden houses. I do not like them.
Well, first of all, let's explore the surroundings. Come with me. Be alert. We do not know what awaits
us. Listen, did I hear you? Above all, do not let them see us. No. Those savages wanted to attack us.
Perhaps their intentions were peaceful. Those savages did not want to share the party with us.
Perhaps they did not understand that we wanted invite them. Oh, oh, it's so hot. I'm tired of
waiting. Where's the rest of the expedition? Be patient, chief. They're driving carts slowing them
down. I'm tired, tired. We're going north, to the sea. King Grey Willis, we're going. Be reasonable,
there aren't enough supplies. Wait for the carts to arrive. You can stay here if you want. We're
going. Good riddance. Those savages again. Clear the way. Did. You see, they're offering us fish.
Those people didn't mean any harm, they just wanted to help us. I don't trust those savages.
look a river the current goes north yes it must go to the sea hey watch out i'm tired of this
country i don't want to go north you just have to stay with kin you'll wait for us here gray
we're going we'll go to the sea north over there let's go good luck where do those people come
from i don't know they have nothing to eat we'll leave something not bad the natives have left us
some cereal cakes those savages could help us by acting as guides but they don't want to they
won't even come close no wonder you've scared them with that many shots they're savages ignorant
people yes come on let's go shoot shoot more salt water the sea is near we'll leave the camels and
go on foot okay let's go the sea is near near i'm sure we can't go any further it's salty we've
reached our goal then we can go back good oh very good finally so will we make it through the year
That's it. They made it. That's what they thought. But it wasn't certain. Then a real tragedy
happened. You see, boss, we've waited for you. It's me. Yes, it's from the other camel. It was
finished. It's dead, boss. We'll reach Qpask soon. They insisted that we stay longer. It's been five
months since they left and we're still waiting. That's it. Okay, right? You're the expedition's
doctor. It's your duty. It's your job to wait. They may be lost. Five months. They're definitely
dead. You may be right. Well, let's go. But we'll leave supplies anyway. They're gone. It means it's
three feet northwest of this tree. We can fit. They left this morning. We'll never catch up with
them. We're too weak and that animal can't stand. Just like us. We have supplies with which we can
survive and leave. But what's there? Unbelievable. It's water. We'll keep going that way. Got my
compass over there. Yes, but he knows the desert. We must guide ourselves by the advances of
civilization. Here, like these seeds, they're edible. But what's that? Look, look, there's
someone over there. It's incredible. It's young King from Burke's expedition. Well, I thought he
was dead. You can see, children, neither Wilson nor Burke returned like the rest of their companions,
but it's thought they made it to the ocean. There you go. Do you remember him? He hadn't arrived yet.
Oh, look, uh, who's coming over there?
Stuart, so, he's made it.
No, I think we were close to the objective, but the aborigines were hostile and set fire
to the brush to prevent us from reaching it.
So, uh, but as soon as we rest and eat something, we'll leave.
I'm so hungry I could eat a kangaroo.
Let's go, let's go.
2,000, 2,100, 2,300 soon.
White men again and they're getting more and more numerous.
Their sheep are eating everything.
There's nothing left for us.
We've had enough.
We must stop them.
They have powerful weapons.
And we have courage.
We must protect our land.
Get ready.
They're coming.
All is well.
This time we'll make it.
But what the hell's going on here?
Shoot over their heads.
Don't kill them.
We don't want to do you any harm.
Let's go to the sea.
There's your gourd.
What do we do with him?
It would be better say your last sentence.
No way.
Defend your country.
We'll let him go.
This worm.
No.
Wait until we turn around him.
Look.
Hey, it's a poisonous snake.
It's deadly.
This man just saved your life.
Oh, how scary.
How scary.
How horrible.
My god.
Thank you, my friend.
You can go.
Come on.
Adabata and Date Party are going.
We shouldn't have let him go.
Huh?
You're forgetting this.
Oh.
I don't have any water either.
Water.
I can't take it anymore.
We need water.
We're going to die of thirst.
To your.
That water is incredible.
How did he know?
Thank you, my friend.
I don't understand how he could find water in a place like this.
In the middle of the desert it seems like magic.
The desert is their land.
They know its secrets.
They're dingoes, desert dogs.
We can't do anything for the horse.
What is this?
A fish.
Can't.
You think of anything?
Sure.
But I've already eaten mine.
And where do fish come from?
Uh, they're coming from the sea or the river.
But I don't know.
It means we're approaching the coast.
Come on.
Here, I'll give you my fish.
This must be the Adelaide River.
it'll take us to the port of Darwin. Dumb. Fast, the rifles. Shoot, but aim well. Did you have to
risk your life for an old hat? Yes, it's my best hat. Thus, on July 25, 1862, two explorers managed
to cross Australia from south to north, a journey of 3,000 kilometers. Today the road discovered by
John MacDonald Stewart is a highway, the Stewart Highway, corners of our world that is constantly
turning, finding roots to trace, always taking a step further, never giving up for the good